.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Anna Rosenwasser ist glücklich.
Es ist der 26. September.
Die Schweiz hat gerade klar mit
über 64 % Ja zur Ehe für alle gesagt.
An der Abstimmungsfeier geniesst
die queere Community den Erfolg.
Ein Erfolg, der vielen gehört.
Und auch ein bisschen ihr:
Anna Rosenwasser, 31,
Aktivistin, Feministin, Influencerin.
Es ist ein Signal,
dass Tausende und Abertausende Leute
in der Schweiz sagen:
"Ihr seid uns wichtig,
ihr verdient Gleichberechtigung."
Das ist nicht nur politisch,
sondern auch sehr persönlich.
Das berührt mega.
Ich musste eine Träne verdrücken.
- Ach, ich schon 20.
Zum ersten Mal heute.
Das klare Abstimmungsergebnis
steht für eine neue gesellschaftliche
Akzeptanz von Queerness.
Und dafür
setzt Anna Rosenwasser sich ein.
Sie kämpft gegen Homophobie,
Sexismus und Diskriminierung.
Und sie tut dies
laut, fordernd, selbstbewusst.
Netter formulieren my ass.
Wer sie Kampflesbe nennt,
macht ihr ein Kompliment.
Ich will eine Gesellschaft,
in der die Suizidrate
von homosexuellen Jugendlichen
nicht fünfmal höher ist.
Politik ist mein Leben.
Es gibt nichts nicht Politisches
an mir.
In den letzten Jahren
war Anna Rosenwasser
als Geschäftsführerin
der Lesbenorganisation Schweiz
eines der wichtigsten Gesichter
der LGBTQ-Szene.
Anna Rosenwasser is from
the Swiss Lesbian Organisation.
Auch in den sozialen Medien.
Ihre Instagram-Posts sind politisch,
persönlich, immer ein bisschen rosa,
aber auch provokant und hässig.
Was steckt hinter
diesem neuen Selbstbewusstsein?
September 2020, ein Jahr zuvor.
Anna bereitet sich
auf eine Queer-Party vor.
Sie will auffallen -
das Queersein zelebrieren.
Ja, das Outfit wird's.
Es gibt auch megaviele Queers,
die sagen:
"Hört auf mit der Abgrenzung,
ihr macht uns einen schlechten Ruf."
"Wir wollen nur
normal und akzeptiert sein."
Ich verstehe
das Bedürfnis nach Normalität.
Aber ich bin nicht
mit der Normalität einverstanden.
Was für eine Normalität ist das,
die mir sagt, dass ich falsch sei?
Dieser Normalität will ich nicht
beweisen, dass ich dazugehöre.
Hoi, Kätzchen.
Heute
findet das Jugendfestival Lila statt,
wo sich die Community
alljährlich trifft.
Eine Community,
die sich in den letzten Jahren
regelrecht
ins Bewusstsein der Öffentlichkeit
und mitten in die Jugendkultur
gespült hat.
Hier feiert sie sich
mit all ihren Buchstaben:
L für lesbisch,
G für gay, also schwul,
B für bisexuell,
T für trans, Q für queer -
der Überbegriff für alle,
deren geschlechtliche Identität
von der Norm abweicht.
* Ruhige Musik *
# Before I sleep, I'll strive, yeah.
Anna Rosenwasser
führt heute durch das Programm.
Bist du nervös?
Ich bin erstaunlicherweise
nicht nervös vor solchen Sachen.
Weil es ein Publikum ist,
von dem ich weiss, dass es mich mag.
Ich könnte es
auch nicht so gut machen
und sie würden mich trotzdem mögen.
Man spricht mit vielen Menschen,
die einen mögen.
Das ist so ein schönes Gefühl.
Das ist etwas vom Schönsten,
das ich im Leben kenne.
Liebe Bitches,
Butches, Dykes und Divas,
willkommen zum zweiten Tag
des Lila-Festivals 2020.
* Jubel und Applaus *
Anlässe wie das Lila-Festival
sind dafür da, um zu sagen:
"Schämen my ass."
Wir sind nicht da und glücklich ...
...  o b w o h l  wir so sind,
wie wir sind.
Wir sind glücklich,
w e i l  wir so sind, wie wir sind.
* Jubel *
Die Antwort auf Scham ist Stolz.
Wer hier drin ist stolz?
* Jubel *
Anna Rosenwasser setzt sich in Szene.
Sie wird gefeiert und geniesst es.
Ist das auch
ein Teil Selbstinszenierung?
Ja, eh.
Es ist ein Teil Selbstinszenierung.
Wenn ich mich nicht gerne
selbst inszenieren würde,
würde ich wohl andere Formen
politischer Arbeit machen.
Viele Leute arbeiten politisch
für dasselbe wie ich,
aber so, dass ihre Visage
nicht omnipräsent ist.
Das sind häufig Dinge,
in denen ich lausig wäre.
Und sie wären lausig darin,
einen Insta-Kanal zu führen,
bei dem sie in die Kamera sprechen.
Wir arbeiten
unseren Stärken entsprechend.
* Elektronisch Musik *
Anna Rosenwasser
mitten in der Community.
Eine Familie, die Selbstbewusstsein
und Zugehörigkeit gibt
und in der Anna
aber auch Vorbild ist.
Ihre Popularität
führt zu einer wachsenden Zahl
von Followern auf Instagram.
Ich hoffe, bei den Tieren hat es
ein Schild mit "Vorsicht, Menschen".
Dass sie selbst queer ist,
hat Anna Rosenwasser
erst vor einigen Jahren entdeckt.
Seit dreieinhalb Jahren
ist sie mit Florina zusammen.
Die beiden
teilen eine gemeinsame Liebe: Katzen.
Sie sind regelmässige
Gäste im Tierheim.
Es schleckt meinen Finger ab.
Anna Rosenwasser
bezeichnet sich als bisexuell,
d.h., dass sie sich zu Männern
und Frauen hingezogen fühlt.
In ihren Jugendjahren war sie aber
ausschliesslich mit Männern zusammen.
Ich dachte einfach, es sei normal,
dass man auch Frauen heiss findet,
weil sie ja überall so
sexualisiert dargestellt werden.
Ich dachte,
das sei normal und gehe allen so.
Ich bezeichnete mich
sehr lange als heterosexuell.
Das kann daran liegen ...
Ich mag androgyne Frauen,
die nicht krass feminin sind.
Ich bin
in einer Kleinstadt aufgewachsen.
Da ist es unüblicher,
dass man als Frau etwas maskuliner
oder androgyner aussieht.
Es gab einfach nicht viele Frauen,
die mein Typ waren.
Ich glaube, wenn Flo in meiner
Kleinstadt rumgelaufen wäre ...
Ich schliesse nicht aus,
dass ich dann schon früher
auf eine Frau gestanden wäre.
Ja, schon gut.
Ja.
Seit einem Jahr
wohnen Florina und Anna zusammen
in einer kleinen Wohnung
im Zürcher Kreis 5.
Die beiden beschäftigt, was viele
Paare in ihrem Alter beschäftigt:
Es wird geheiratet im Freundeskreis.
Sie selbst haben ein zwiespältiges
Verhältnis zu Hochzeiten.
Wollt ihr heiraten?
Manchmal sagen wir: "Ja, voll."
Manchmal finden wir auch,
dass wir der Gesellschaft dieses
Goodie gar nicht geben wollen.
Und manchmal finden wir,
dass wir der Gesellschaft
dieses Goodie geben wollen,
damit sie sieht, dass es ver-
schiedene Arten des Heiratens gibt -
nicht nur Braut und Bräutigam.
Wir finden die Vorstellung
noch herzig,
aber machen unsere Beziehung
nicht daran fest.- Nein.
Wir finden ... Ich glaube,
mit dem Zusammenzug vor einem Jahr
ist der grösste Schritt gemacht.
Der nächste ist eine grössere
Wohnung mit einer Katze.
Dann brauche ich nichts mehr.
- Zwei Katzen.
Stimmt.
Erlaubt ist dem Paar das Heiraten
zu diesem Zeitpunkt aber noch nicht.
Es ist erst ein Gedankenspiel.
Das wäre einer der Hauptgründe,
dich zu heiraten:
Um unsere Playlist laufen zu lassen.
Ich dachte, Änni legt auf.
- Ja, gut. Änni kann auflegen.
Das ist super.
Ihr hättet eigentlich alles geplant.
- Ja, vieles.
Wir wissen auch schon wo
und wo wir essen.
Tatsache. Stimmt.
Wir haben schon darüber geredet,
wen wir einladen.
Wir haben eine Liste,
die wir aktualisieren.
Als Geschäftsführerin
der Lesbenorganisation Schweiz
ist Anna Rosenwasser
zu Besuch in St. Gallen,
an der Soirée
einer queeren Studentenorganisation.
An erster Stelle
steht hier das gerade
wichtigste Thema der Community:
Der lange Kampf für die Ehe für alle.
Ich will Gleichberechtigung
und habe es satt, zu warten.
Ich bin 30
und habe es schon satt zu warten.
Man stelle sich vor,
wie es unseren Vorkämpferinnen ging.
Ich habe ein bisschen Geschichte
studiert und ich habe gelernt,
dass soziale Bewegungen
und Veränderung in der Gesellschaft
nicht dadurch kamen,
dass Leute sagten:
"Entschuldigung, könnten wir ein
bisschen mehr Gerechtigkeit haben?"
"Nur ein bisschen? Bitte."
Nein. Leute waren extrem wütend
und forderten alles -
die komplette Gleichberechtigung.
Und das mache ich auch.
* Applaus *
Anna Rosenwasser
gibt sich kämpferisch.
Das kommt beim Publikum an.
Sie hat es megagut gemacht.
Ich war
beeindruckt von ihren Argumenten.
Ich würde sie gerne mal
in einer Debatte sehen.
Es war eindrücklich,
wie sie das rübergebracht hat, ja.
Ich finde es spannend, wie sie
aus ihrer Generation argumentiert
oder auch agiert.
Gibt es Dinge, die Sie kritisieren
und die Ihre Generation
anders gemacht hat?
Darauf war ich gespannt.
Dafür bin ich gekommen.
Ich fragte mich, ob
etwas davon verloren gegangen sei,
was wir erreichen wollten
oder auch erreicht haben.
Aber ich finde,
mit ihr ging es nicht verloren,
im Gegenteil.
Es wurde transformiert
und weiterentwickelt.
Wenn sie das in ihrer Generation
weiterverbreiten kann,
ist das ein totaler Gewinn -
auch für uns.
Von Gleichgesinnten erhält
Anna Rosenwasser viel Zuspruch.
Aber wie sieht es
ausserhalb der Blase aus?
Unterwegs
mit ihrem jüngeren Bruder Dan.
Er beobachtet die Welt seiner
Schwester mit kritischer Distanz.
Also ...
Wenn man
nicht zur LGBTQI-Bubble gehört
und man sich als "Normaler" sieht,
ist es natürlich befremdlich.
Sie zelebrieren sich selbst.
Sie zelebrieren die Schwulheit
oder die Transsexualität.
Dann gibt es all die Dinge
wie Dragshows und so.
Das ist natürlich komisch für mich.
Das ist mir etwas fremd.
Da zähle ich mich nicht dazu.
Aber grundsätzlich finde ich cool,
was sie macht.
Sie setzt sich
für verschiedene Minderheiten ein.
Die effektiven Änderungen,
für die sie sich einsetzt -
z.B. die Ehe für alle
oder Vaterschaftsurlaub -,
die sind mega.
Ich finde es voll okay,
wenn diese Welt
für dich befremdlich ist.
Aber wenn wir darüber diskutieren,
könnte es schon emotional werden.
Das ist potenziell schon heikel.
Ich will nicht unbedingt ...
Ich will es geniessen,
wenn wir zusammen sind.- Voll.
Heute diskutieren sie aber.
Die beiden besuchen eine Ausstellung
im Stapferhaus in Lenzburg
zum Thema Geschlechteridentitäten.
Anna Rosenwasser
hat die Ausstellungsmachenden beraten
und selbst mitgewirkt.
Das ist Hass
gegen besonders feminine Frauen.
Als wäre das eine falsche Art,
eine Frau zu sein.
(Frau) Dass wir
in einer binären Gesellschaft leben,
die nur zwei Geschlechter kennt,
schränkt v.a. unser Denken ein.
Ja, was ist binär?
Es tun alle so,
als gäbe es nur Mann und Frau.
Mann ist immer so, Frau immer so.
- Nicht immer, aber generell.
Die Grundrichtung ist binär.
Mich würde vor den Kopf stossen,
wenn man sich
speziell verhalten würde.
Wenn man schwuchtlig tut
oder als Frau extra männlich,
um als Butch-Lesbe rüberzukommen.
Aber meine Partnerin
ist ja voll der Tomboy.
Sie ist ja überhaupt nicht feminin.
- Ja.
Findest du das auch blöd?
- Nein.
Sie ist voll okay.
Ich habe nichts gegen sie.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
woher das kommt.
Das Geschlecht als Spielwiese.
Die traditionellen Rollen
von Mann und Frau aufgeweicht.
Für Anna eine Notwendigkeit -
für ihren Bruder eine Provokation.
Ich glaube, ich und ein Grossteil
der Leute verstehen das falsch.
So: "Ach, das Genderzeugs."
Man denkt, alle könnten alles machen
und Biologie bedeute nichts.
Nicht "Biologie bedeutet nichts".
Biologie bedeutet etwas,
aber sie wird stark überschätzt.
Okay.
Dass ich eine Frau bin,
sagt nichts darüber aus,
ob ich Babys will oder was ich
im Leben mag oder nicht.
Es ist eine schöne Freiheit
zu sagen,
dass es megaviele Formen
von Frausein gibt.
Okay.
Eine Diskussion,
die noch nicht zu Ende ist.
Aber zumindest für einen Nachmittag
scheinen auch die Rollen
zwischen Bruder und Schwester
nicht mehr ganz so klar verteilt.
Wow, nicht schlecht.
Ich trainiere jeden Tag, kein Witz.
- Ohne Scheiss? Das ist mega.
Du warst auch erstaunt,
als wir boxten. Ich trainiere.
Du bist brutal.
Krass, Mann. Alter.
- Jö, du bist so süss.
* Lachen *
Krass.
Mit Anna Rosenwassers
wachsender Bekanntheit
hat auch
die Arbeitsbelastung zugenommen.
Das hat einen Preis.
Vor wenigen Tagen
hat sie eine Entscheidung getroffen.
"Guten Morgen, liebes Team."
"Ich schreibe euch diese Mail,
um zu erzählen,
dass auch ich meinen Job
bei der LOS abgeben werden."
"Genau genommen ist das Timing
meiner Erschöpfung geschuldet."
"Ginge es
nach Überzeugung und Freude,
würde ich noch
jahrelang bei der LOS bleiben."
Es gab in diesen dreieinhalb Jahren
immer wieder Phasen,
in denen der Stress mich wirklich
an die Grenzen gebracht hat.
Ich weiss, dass es als normal gilt,
bis zur Erschöpfung zu arbeiten.
Aber damit
bin ich nicht einverstanden.
Neben der Festanstellung
bei der Lesbenorganisation
arbeitet Anna
als Kolumnistin und Autorin.
Mit Schreiben und Auftritten
will sie sich von nun an
den Lebensunterhalt verdienen.
Ein Sprung ins Ungewisse.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es
mit der öffentlichen Aufmerksamkeit
für meine Tätigkeit und Person
weitergeht.
Das hat sich nicht so entwickelt,
weil ich das so geplant hatte.
Das hat eine Eigendynamik,
die ich nur begrenzt steuern kann.
Es kann auch sein,
dass in einem halben Jahr
niemand mehr etwas
von Anna Rosenwasser wissen will.
Dann
würden die Aufträge runtergehen.
Zum Wohl.
- (Leute) Zum Wohl.
Schön,
dass ich wieder mal dabei sein kann.
Soll gelten. Zum Wohl dort drüben.
Santé.
Nur noch selten
ist Anna Rosenwasser in der Heimat
in Flurlingen zu Besuch.
Hier im Zürcher Weinland
ist sie aufgewachsen.
Noch immer
treffen sich ihre Verwandten
hier jeden Samstag zum Mittagessen.
Die Familie
verfolgt Annas Aktivismus genau.
Sie war schon als kleines Mädchen
sehr aktiv.
Schon?- Ja, ja.
- Ich redete einfach immer gerne.
Man musste Anna
wirklich jeweils stoppen,
damit ihre Geschwister ...
- ... etwas beitragen durften.
... etwas sagen konnten.
Ich bin immer stolz, auch wenn es
negative Bewertungen gibt.
Das stört mich nicht.
- Was hörst du Negatives?
Es gibt Leute, die einfach
eine andere Meinung haben.
Sie finden, du seist etwas extrem.
Denen gebe ich recht: "Ja, ja."
Dass ich extrem bin, höre ich auch.
- Es braucht Extreme.
Ohne Extreme gibt es keine Mitte.
- Richtig.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass das extrem ist.
Du setzt dich leidenschaftlich
für etwas Sozialpolitisches ein.
Das kommt nicht von ungefähr.
Das haben wir
in der Familie mitgekriegt.
Dass man sich
für die Schwachen einsetzt.
Wir diskutierten früher auch heiss.
Ja.
Das Drumherum, die Medienpräsenz -
da gibt es Für und Wider.
Man kann Themen platzieren,
aber man ist auch ausgesetzt.
Die erste Nachricht,
die ich heute Morgen gelesen habe,
war eine kritische Nachricht
irgendeines Heinz' zu meiner Arbeit.
Das sollte nicht das Erste sein,
das ich lese.
Wenigstens geht es um die Arbeit
und nicht um etwas Oberflächliches.
Aber Diskussionen zu meinem Inhalt
treffen mich mehr
als oberflächliche Beleidigungen.
Da gibt es
schon auch eine Empfindlichkeit.
Empfindlich sein
ist nichts Schlechtes.- Nein.
D.h. ja, dass man verletzlich ist.
Ich will mir
keine dicke Haut anschaffen,
weil es Leute auf der Welt gibt,
die mir keine Rechte zugestehen.
Ja.
- Ich will empfindlich bleiben.
Aber es ist ein Unterschied,
ob du deine Rechte einforderst
oder ob du einfach betupft bist.
Vielleicht ist es ja nicht betupft,
sondern verletzt.
Ruft mir jemand
"Dreckslesbe" hinterher,
ist die Diskussion nicht,
ob ich verletzt bin oder nicht.
Ich bin es.
Ist diese neue Generation
der Aktivistinnen empfindlich?
Regt sie sich zu sehr
über Kleinigkeiten auf?
Oder ist sie verletzlicher,
als das selbstbewusste Auftreten
vermuten lässt?
Tschau, Nonna.
- Bis bald. Trag dir Sorge.
Du dir auch.
- Ja.
Wir haben beide Leute um uns,
die uns Sorge tragen.
Genau. Wir sind nicht alleine.
- Wir sind nicht alleine.
Hier in Flurlingen
ist Anna aufgewachsen.
Hier kann sie auch mal eine andere
sein als in der Öffentlichkeit.
Wie ist Ihre Anna?
Meine Anna ist kuschelig, nuschelig.
Im Gegensatz zu den Themen,
die sie vertritt
und für die sie sich einsetzt ...
Da muss sie sehr kämpferisch sein.
Hier ist sie halt:
essen,
schlafen, büseln, kuscheln ...
Ja.
Wohlfühlen. Zuhause halt.
Machen Sie sich manchmal auch Sorgen,
dass Anna
sich dieser Öffentlichkeit aussetzt?
Ja, schon. Also, Sorgen ...
Solange ich das Gefühl habe,
sie habe es im Griff
und gute Menschen um sie herum,
die das mit ihr machen,
mache ich mir keine Sorgen.
Aber ich denke,
es ist ziemlich brutal.
Ich will all diese E-Mails
und Rückmeldungen aus dem Internet
nicht sehen.
Nein.
Deshalb mache ich da nicht mit.
Ich will dieser Masse an ungehemmten
Äusserungen - ich nenne es so -
nicht ausgesetzt sein.
Das möchte ich nicht.
Anna Rosenwasser ist hier
zusammen
mit ihren drei jüngeren Brüdern,
Mutter und Vater aufgewachsen.
Ihre Eltern haben sich getrennt,
als sie ein Teenager war.
Über ihren Vater
will Anna in diesem Film nicht reden.
Aber er hat sie geprägt.
Auch
durch seine jüdische Zugehörigkeit.
Ich sollte mit Kinderbüchern
Hebräisch lernen.
Das ist viel besser,
als mein Hebräisch-Lernprogramm.
Ich glaube, meine jüdischen Wurzeln
haben dazu beigetragen,
dass ich gelernt habe,
dass man sich gewisse
Zugehörigkeiten nicht aussucht.
Und sie brachten mir bei ...
... welche Formen von
Diskriminierung wie funktionieren.
Ich gehe
als eine Person durch die Welt,
die offiziell nicht jüdisch ist,
aber
immer für jüdisch gehalten wird.
Das bringt mir viel bei.
Seit Annas Kündigung ist sie
in den Medien präsenter denn je -
zu allen möglichen Themen.
- Willkommen im "Literaturclub".
Wurde es viel militanter
gegenüber der Political Correctness?
Ist der Cis-Mann der neue Buhmann?
- Nein, das würde ich nicht sagen.
Dabei kommt sie unterschiedlich an:
"Charmant und konstruktiv"
sagen die einen,
"vorlaut und aggressiv" die anderen.
Die Zahl der Follower wächst weiter.
Gerade mit ihrem Instagram-Auftritt
polarisiert und provoziert
Anna Rosenwasser.
Mit Absicht?
Ich bin Jahrgang 1990.
Ich kommuniziere in Memes.
Ich verstehe, dass das
als provokant wahrgenommen wird.
Ich bin manchmal durchaus hässig
und drücke mich auch so aus.
Das
wird als Provokation wahrgenommen.
Das ist okay für mich.
Das Rezept scheint aufzugehen.
Bereits verdient sie auf Instagram
mit bezahlter Werbung Geld.
Und eine Agentur hat angeklopft,
die sie managen will.
Die grössere Reichweite
hat allerdings auch Schattenseiten.
Auch die Zahl
der Hassnachrichten steigt.
Vor Kurzem schrieb irgendein
20-jähriger Fremder auf Instagram,
ich sei so hässlich,
dass mich nicht mal
jemand vergewaltigen wollen würde.
Höchstens
vielleicht notgeile Asylanten.
Was macht das mit einem,
wenn man so etwas liest?
Ja, schwierig zu sagen.
Einerseits fühlt man Ekel.
Und ein Unwohlsein,
dass Leute einen so scheisse finden,
dass sie das schreiben.
Hallo.
Hoi.
- Hu-hu.
Anna Rosenwassers Arbeit
bei der Lesbenorganisation
neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Im Büro in Bern
übergibt sie ihre Aufgaben
an eine ihrer Nachfolgerinnen.
Hast du noch etwas anderes offen,
als den WhatsApp-Newsletter?
Nö.
Rund vier Jahre lang war Anna
bei der Lesbenorganisation LOS.
Was hat sie bewirkt?
Du hast eine neue Öffentlichkeit
geschaffen, auch für junge Lesben.
Für junge bisexuelle Menschen.
Das hat der LOS in den letzten
Jahren zu sehr viel verholfen.
Danke.
Dass Anna Rosenwasser
zu einem Vorbild
für junge, queere Frauen wurde,
zeigt sich auch
an ihren sog. Treffpunkten.
Schön, dich zu sehen.
Anna hat diese Treffpunkte
ins Leben gerufen.
Die Idee: Junge Menschen
versammeln sich als Gruppe
und gehen gemeinsam
an eine Queer-Party.
Ihr seid ab jetzt
offiziell mit mir unterwegs.
Wenn ihr euch irgendwann alleine
fühlt oder Begleitung möchtet,
um kurz rauszugehen
für einen stillen Moment oder so,
könnt ihr euch immer an mich hängen,
ihr nervt mich nie.
Okay? Wichtige Regel: Ihr nervt nie.
Ihr könnt zu mir kommen,
dann gehört ihr zu mir -
falls das
ein Bedürfnis ist für euch.
(Beide) Who run the world?
- (Alle) Queers!
(Beide) Who run the world? -
Fantastisch, wir gehen los.
Die Gruppe soll Sicherheit geben Ð
z.B. denen,
die neu in der Community sind.
Es kommen junge Menschen
aus der ganzen Schweiz.
Heute zu einer Party
in der Roten Fabrik in Zürich.
Ich wäre wohl nicht gekommen,
wenn sie nicht gesagt hätten,
dass wir uns vorher treffen
und dann zusammen hierhin kommen.
Ich hätte mich nicht getraut,
alleine hierherzukommen.
Es hat so viele Leute - ich wüsste
nicht, zu wem ich gehen sollte.
Zu wissen, dass Leute hier sind,
die ich kurz kennenlernen konnte,
ist eine coole Sache.
Wir sind zum Treffpunkt gekommen,
weil wir alle ein bisschen
Einzelgängerinnen und -gänger sind.
Anna gibt uns Sicherheit
und lässt uns nie alleine.
Ich folge ihr noch nicht so lange.
Aber es ging dann recht schnell,
bis ich mich geoutet habe.
Sie ist eine Art Wegbegleiterin.
Sie hat Ihr Outing inspiriert?
- Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Sie hat die schönen Seiten
aufgezeigt.
Wenn man merkt,
dass man nicht hetero ist ...
... sieht und findet man
nur die schlechten Seiten.
Dann "kommt" eine Anna daher
und man sieht,
dass es megaschön ist.
Sie ist megaglücklich
und das inspiriert einfach.
Das finde ich sehr berührend.
Das gibt mir die Energie,
um weiterzumachen.
Ich versuche ja eigentlich,
die Person zu sein,
die ich früher gerne gehabt hätte.
Ich finde es sehr berührend,
dass ich das manchmal schaffe.
Es ist nicht nur
das Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl,
das den jungen Menschen hilft.
Es ist auch die Stärke einer Gruppe,
die Schutz bietet vor Übergriffen.
Es ist weniger scary,
als alleine als Queer unterwegs
zu sein und an eine Party zu gehen.
Es ist schön,
wenn man zusammenkommen kann.
Wieso scary?- Weil es je nachdem
schon nicht einfach ist,
alleine unterwegs zu sein.
Man hat Angst,
dumm angemacht zu werden.
Als Gruppe ist man geschützt.
Ja, es ist ein Safe Space.
Das ist megaschön.
Wenn man sonst als Frau,
die Frauen liebt,
mit einer anderen Frau
unterwegs ist,
wird man
immer noch dumm angemacht.
Das ist megaschwierig.
Ständig
an die eigene Sicherheit denken -
für queere Menschen
immer noch eine Realität.
Das grosse Engagement
zehrt an Anna Rosenwassers Kräften.
Sich selber Sorge tragen,
wird deshalb immer mehr zum Thema.
In letzter Zeit hat sie
mehrmals Einladungen ausgeschlagen -
zu Streitgesprächen
mit Gegnern der Ehe für alle.
Gelegenheiten,
die sie früher wahrgenommen hat,
lässt sie nun auch mal verstreichen.
Ich habe in den letzten Monaten
gelernt,
dass ich nicht zu jeder Gelegenheit
Ja sagen muss
und dass "Nein, danke" sagen
auch eine gesunde Form
von Grenzen setzen ist.
Ich kann ja nicht allen anderen
etwas Gutes tun und mir nicht.
Das geht nicht auf.
Aber
gerade als politische Aktivistin
müsste man
auch andere Meinungen aushalten
und nicht nur in der eigenen Blase
bleiben, wo man nur bestätigt wird?
Ich kann mich auch mit kritischen
Gegenstimmen auseinandersetzen,
ohne dass ich das aushalten muss.
In dem Moment, in dem mir
ein politischer Gegner sagt,
dass ich keine Rechte verdient habe,
macht das etwas mit mir.
Es ist wichtig, dass ich
sorgsam mit meiner Energie umgehe.
Es ist Abstimmungssonntag.
Ein Tag, der auch persönlich
etwas für Anna Rosenwasser verändert.
Jetzt sieht es noch mal anders aus.
Jetzt können wir uns
zum ersten Mal in unserer Beziehung
die Frage stellen,
ob wir heiraten wollen.
Die Antwort? Wer weiss.
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Die Antwort ist nicht mehr
"Nein, wir dürfen nicht",
sondern:
"Nein, wir wissen es noch nicht."
Es ist schön,
diese Freiheit zu haben.
Ein Freudentag.
Und trotzdem
ist Anna Rosenwasser froh,
dass der Abstimmungskampf
nun vorbei ist.
* Jubel *
Das könnte ich nicht die ganze Zeit.
Was ich die ganze Zeit machen
könnte, ist Community-Arbeit.
Das ist eine sehr dankbare Arbeit.
Ich sehe jeden Tag, was es bringt
und dass es Sinn ergibt.
Das ist wichtiger als alles andere.
Weiterkämpfen,
aber mit Fokus auf die Community.
Sie ist es,
die Anna Rosenwasser die Kraft
und Motivation gibt, weiterzumachen.
Denn die Arbeit
ist für sie längst nicht zu Ende.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021